(guitar strumming)
(distant applause)
- I think there's something about
the more difficult it
is to get to a place,
it seems like it's more
valuable when you're there.
(chanting)
As a photographer, my end goal really is
to make people see the landscape
in a completely new perspective.
It's about showing things
in a different light.
I don't really see
myself as a photographer.
Um, I see myself as an artist
working with photography.
Well, I've always been pretty
obsessed with mountains.
Rock formations and pinnacles
and that kind of thing.
Growing up in Liverpool,
glaciers were always something
that I had never really
had that much access to.
When I was approached by Coors Light,
to shoot in an incredible place like this,
I thought it was a really great chance
to show something which
wasn't seen before.
The color of the ice underneath
the light of the drone.
Tomorrow, if we can go into Pastoruri
in order to get to a
really good viewpoint,
we have to hike.
New experiences are crucial for me.
I just explore and see where it takes me.
Wow.
The scale of this place
is just incredible.
- Probably, like, it's gonna get tougher
on this walk.
- Yeah, I know it gets steep somewhere.
I don't mind going a little bit higher.
I think there's more to discover.
Tonight, I do wanna come away
with compositions which
are quite a bit different.
(exciting music)
(flute)
When the full moon comes up,
everything is gonna be bathed in light.
So, I think it will be a
good idea to start shooting,
like, now-ish.
One of the things about
exploring a landscape
for me is being able to shoot at night.
I've been using drones with
lights attached to them
and that allows me to
illuminate the landscape
as you would in a studio.
That was kind of the challenge,
trying to see in the dark.
Everything is more
difficult at this altitude.
(distant) No, no, no, no.
That shoot was kinda low
and it kind of landed badly.
It's mainly this.
I started losing fingers
in my index finger
and middle finger.
(laugh)
I can't even speak properly
’cause it's so cold.
I’d like to test this again
just to see if it works.
(haunting music)
With this project, I
was seeking to produce
a series of images that tells a story
of this place and express
my own ideas of exploration.
I don't think I'll ever stop exploring.
That's what it comes down to.
Going out of your comfort zone.
You know, each time you do something,
just push a little bit further.